hello and welcome to today's session all
about being great PPC tips for Microsoft
Advertising are you curious about
expanding your pay-per-click advertising
beyond Google Ads well today we're
taking a fresh and detailed look at
Microsoft advertising formerly known as
Bing ads whether you're new to this
platform or you want to learn what's new
about its unique capabilities such as
the integration of targeting data from
LinkedIn well you're going to be glad to
be part of this conversation now in
addition to simply learn to resident
pay-per-click expert bread gedda's we're
joined by a special guest John Lee
Microsoft advertising learning
strategist Brad and John will discuss
the growing and evolving ecosystem of
Microsoft advertising formerly known as
Bing ads and we're going to learn how to
easily import your campaigns ads and
targeting and even your shopping product
feeds to get this conversation started I
just want to introduce us to brad geddes
he's the author of advanced google
adwords and the co-founder of the
award-winning company analysis
Brad frequently writes columns for
search engine land co-moderators the
AdWords forum on webmaster world and
he's keynoted and spoken at more than
125 conferences has led more than 100
seminars Brad it's really good to have
you here with us again and talking about
something other than Google another
thanks Dan we speak a lot about Google
or PPC strategy in general but there's
this other platform out there with a
pretty solid reach we probably don't
talk about enough so it's sort of good
this today we have someone I've known
for I don't know 10 years 12 years and
is often on panels that I'm either
speaking on or I'm moderating and I need
a good speaker
turn to John so what everyone is really
you to pay attention to John today as
Microsoft has some really cool import
from Google fast starts with but you got
to know some details some fun details
behind that instant features Google just
doesn't have John's our learning
strategist at Microsoft
he's previously been in agencies and and
written a lot
supposed to be a great time with John so
John welcome and thanks for being here
today Brad thank you for having me Dan
likewise it's a pleasure to be here so
yeah happy to have any talk search
having to talk digital advertising and
specifically because they pay my
paycheck having talked Microsoft
advertising as well so and everyone I do
want to make a note real quick John a
lot of times you have the the speakers
from the companies who only toe the
corporate line right who are like nope
Google gave me this deck or Microsoft
gave me this deck I got to do and I can
only say things this way John used to
run an agency John has a lot of expense
warning accounts so he's going to tell
you what you actually need to know
because Bing is very open with people if
this is what we're good at this is what
we're bad at and they'll tell you both
which is a really refreshing viewpoint
so don't take this at from someone who
works for Microsoft although that's a
you know good star on the resume taking
someone who actually knows what they're
doing and spends all day in this
platform Thank You Brad oh and and it's
it's true the right context means
everything and Microsoft Advertising
formerly known as Bing ads without the
context of what's happening on Google
you know direct competition but even
what's happening within the industry at
large we think about retail and native
advertising all these different things
context is king if it's to that end I
will I will toe the company line ever so
briefly here to get things kicked off
and only because as you heard Dan
mention at the grad you mentioned it and
now I mentioned it is that as a as a
business we just went through a
rebranding exercise and so many of you
likely know us as Bing ads we are now
Microsoft advertising and so you know a
lot of you I'm sure like well it does
should have been called it all along I'm
in that camp as well you know but it
does it helps us align with with the big
business all above Microsoft but thank
you for transformation right that's what
this is all about you know we've have a
culture internally of really being about
people and that shows in the way that we
build relationships it shows in the way
that we even develop the product
a lot of user feedback it's all there
and so when we know that brands as a
whole are built by piece of people and
that instills trust and so from there
then what does that mean well we're
going to be doing our part to protect
your data again not doing stupid stuff
with it exporting in places it shouldn't
go aggregating things in what you see
with data and targeting and restricting
bias and targeting groups I mean we've
all we've all been hearing about tech
lash right over the last year two years
or so we are very cognizant of that as
well and so want to make sure that we're
doing right by you the customer focused
on people here we talk a lot about
audience today in various times and so
whether it's your data our data
somewhere in the middle all of that
means amazing targeting for you the
advertiser and of course being that we
are Microsoft there's this massive
ecosystem that we get to tap into we
call it the Microsoft graph that does
now include LinkedIn but if you think
about office and all the different
devices whether it's just pcs with
running Windows but even now you know
mobile both phones as well as tablets
running office and all the different
Microsoft apps that are out there if
actually just discovered that today that
whiteboard which is one of my personal
favorite Microsoft apps even that ones
on on Macs now so we're everywhere
powered businesses to build a success so
looking at how can we deliver customer
insights personal experiences you know
thinking through with you the client
customer experience and of course
acquiring and nurturing helping you
acquire in deter your own business as
well so there's a lot there hopefully
you've spared me that moment to toe the
company line um just give me one more
minute so as we think about reach Brad
mentioned reach you know we as Microsoft
advertising still do rely heavily on PC
traffic I don't want to mince words
about that and so when I referenced
these numbers and growth that we've seen
over the last few years in terms of
global search share this is referencing
PCs however that's not the end of the
story we are see
growth across devices again whether it's
pcs or what's happening with you know
voice you know think it's not just
Cortana like where Cortana is also the
skillset for Alexa and vice versa
but you have Xbox activity baked into
all of that a lot of John go back one
slide real quick though go back to your
PC share yeah so so one of the things we
hear a lot from people is I hate mobile
because we're business-to-business your
hand while b2b is growing a bit on
mobile um
Microsoft ads has traditionally been one
of most you know PPC people who spent
time in paid search one of the favorite
places because there's a lot of desktop
share and it's a slightly different user
base so it isn't it it follows common
sense to Brad right so like if you think
about who is the dominant operating
system in business
well it's Windows right so that's
Microsoft and and what devices are
people using when they're at work well
their work computer it's a lot of those
are stuck on on defaults right so like
if you follow the breadcrumb that stands
to reason that a lot of people are going
to be doing business related searches
from work on a work device and so that
does play in our favor and that's one of
our hardest problems though is guessing
which is what we can spend on bing
because if you look at this right you
might just say oh we can spend a third
what we spend on Google on bing I'm when
they're 36% query share it's but it
wouldn't be right if you're in retail
where there's a lot of mobile it's
probably 18% 20% if you're in b2b it
very well could be a third so it's
always someone just to keep in mind when
as many budgets for Bank based upon
search share stuff I had a coin sort of
in about four years ago that it was
spending close to a million dollars a
month
b2b advertising and you looked at search
always to take display and other
activities out of that search only we
were at about a 55/45 split 45% going to
being and spending all day long and so
it again it very
is on vertical it you know varies on a
lot of things it does vary on market of
course as you can see in this this chart
to so that's an excellent point
keep going yeah so mobile is something
that we hear a lot of people constantly
asking us what are you doing about
mobile you're doing about mobile we are
making gains they're not huge gains just
beyond that we are making gains you know
a lot of that admittedly comes from our
partner Network and so I will go into a
little more detail on this
well we won't hang out here for long but
there's always a surprise in here for
people in terms of like oh I didn't
realize that Microsoft advertising was
serving ads here or there so hopefully
hopefully there's a surprise there for
you and then when we think about search
right the story is not done there's a
lot of development happening but we do
have a lot of efforts happening outside
of search so looking at native
advertising and what we call the
Microsoft audience Network and so when
you bring all of that together and
that's a massive reach and I will go
into a lot more detail on the audience
that work soon so we'll take a quick
breather there and take a deep breath
take a quick sip of my iced coffee
let's jump in getting started with
Microsoft advertising and again if you
are not currently on the platform
hopefully I've laid things out so it's a
bit of a primer just a lay of the land
if you will and giving you some steps to
jump in quickly if you are on the
platform again hopefully there's tidbits
nestled in there that you didn't know or
maybe you forgot so one of the the best
pieces here and it is not an exclusive
to us but just illustrating that you can
manage your ads web that UI there's also
the Microsoft Advertising editor still
getting used to calling it that may for
short they may e we also do have a
mobile app and while you can't do an
extensive them out those optimizations
say there it is what Brad and i's mutual
friend madman wagner used to call the
big red button so you're out and about
you're out to dinner and your client
calls you hey you know XYZ happened and
we need to pause our ads right now well
it used to be you couldn't do anything
about it unless you like you know have
an employee on speed dial so that was
near a computer now with these apps you
literally can just go in and start
pausing things on the fly so there's a
lot to be said there it's actually one
of the subtle things that's happened in
our industry in the last couple years
not a lot of people talk about it but
it's a super convenient application both
on the Google side and the Microsoft
side
so now let's really get into the meat
and potatoes here so one of the things
that the my crop advertising has really
flexed its muscle on for several years
now is the ability for you to scale from
Google ads out right and directly to us
and so that's the Google ads import the
feature and what that means is is that
you can in just a couple of clicks go
from no campaigns to saying okay I want
to import from Google I'm going to do a
read-only sign in which is effectively
saying it's going to look at the data in
the Google API and then effectively map
it to our system and basically
reconstructed there and it happens
insanely fast and if you're the type of
advertiser is like you know what I just
I don't have enough of my personal
bandwidth or my team's bandwidth to make
changes at Google as I make changes to
being particularly for like running a
new flight of ads or what have you
well we've got you covered there as well
so once you've initiated this this
import sync you can schedule it as well
so whether that be daily weekly monthly
you know if you have a particularly the
more like you know I want to make sure
that the ads that I've written to Google
because that's where I spend most of my
time are also servicing in Microsoft
Advertising absolutely can do that and
so seems super simple there were a lot
of strings to be pulled developer stop
that Evan I think John before we get
into the strings we pulled um so if
you're syncing your Google ads to your
Bing ads accounts does that
automatically include all data or can
you say only campaigns or only ads and
ad groups great great point so if you if
you decide you want to do a scheduled
import even if you just do do it one-off
you have the ability to say I only want
to import this campaign or set of
campaigns you can also say I want to do
only the set of campaigns and only new
items right okay doing it's doing a like
a matrix comparison
essentially vlookup to say okay does
this ad already exist if it does great
don't bring it over right so you'll want
to duplicate it now does that bring over
campaign settings every time if you tell
it to look for net new yes
so here's my question sorry if you if
you don't check the like only look for
new and would be looking at those
settings correct okay so how does a user
manage bidding if they're setting bids
in Google and they want different bids
in Bing or if Google is using target
Ross which Bing does it is a lawyer and
that guy did so what happens when
there's things that aren't inconsistent
the first time you do it we're going to
get this in a second everyone so don't
worry well there's some important things
to double-check but from an ongoing
basis are there other flags that cause
problems if you do automated scheduling
to sync these there certainly can be bit
bid is a line item though that can be
checked to be on or off right in terms
of do you want this to be brought over
each time and so that is a catch now to
your point around say a bid strategy
like max clicks or max CPA or target CPA
something along those lines those those
inherently have a default a default
setting right so if it's max clicks my
max CPC is 50 cents or a dollar whatever
the case may be I to be honest it's a
bit of a gotcha question Brad I would
have to go back I'll check
so I recommend people to scheduling I
mean I so I mean I love the import I use
the import a lot if I make a new
campaign in Google I import it to being
using this feature because I don't want
to go recreate it but I just reinforce
something once paused for two months and
then I know hey you know what some
exchange I'm just going to resync the
whole thing
route leave and one off but it's really
you scheduling so that is a tremendously
deep question and love that question
because you're right so I see a sink
import this this particular scheduling
feature like if you are super small
advertiser and by that I mean you know
business is small right every business
is business is big right to know what
those running them but you know in terms
of like small budget there's not a whole
lot of changes happening and you're
looking for a super simple way to say
okay I need to make one action and have
it be reflected in two different
platforms this could be a great way to
handle that however if you are at a
scale where you've got things moving and
you're you are making management changes
at Google and there's enough activity in
myself advertising making changes there
as well the the argument starts to
falter pretty quick and to be frank I am
in the mind of and I would have made the
same argument three years ago before I
came to work for Microsoft advertising
is Microsoft advertising is its own
channel and so it you know import is
great to get a leg up and get things
kick-started right with very minimal
effort you just click a couple buttons
and the wait for it to sync that's
awesome but from that point on it is its
own channel and so therefore it's going
to have its own performance metrics its
own idiosyncrasies whatever is happening
behind the scenes it needs to be tracked
and monitored as its own thing and
therefore managed as its own thing so
just an FYI
that's my students yeah I mean we're you
know we're a management platform right
and so of people who have both Bing and
Google and our accounts in our system we
find that after about six months there's
a good 20% difference between two
identical cats cause that's identically
if they're really managing both so
they're they're definitely some
differences that don't fall completely
all right excellent a surprise the
difference is in query data as a search
query data but also if you're doing you
know a be testing with your ads or even
with landing pages because it is serving
different audiences yes there's an
overlap but you know there are also
distinct audiences here that your
performance results may vary
yeah our ads are we see the biggest
difference Center yes yep are excellent
keep down please yeah so you know once
you've done the import then things again
it is its own unique channel right and
so that's a lot of what we want to cover
here today is
you know hey keep a watchful eye yes
it's easy to do and make sure that you
tread carefully
so one of the first things to raise the
flag on is in regards to time zones and
AD schedules and this is something I
think a lot of people like to bring up
because it's one of the easiest easiest
differences between the two platforms to
discuss right so with Google Ads and you
said an ad schedule that ad schedule is
based on you the advertiser it's based
on your time zone whereas on the
Microsoft advertising the ad schedule is
based on the users time zone so it's
more of a global setting versus a it's
for me and I'm managing this so it's
based on my time zone so those are very
different very different pieces um you
know honestly like I did sadly I didn't
think about this a lot before I was in
the Microsoft advertising world behind
the scenes I would argue that this is a
better way to do it right it doesn't
make it easier for you to set set your
targeting from an ad schedule
perspective cause I mean dude I remember
I just said dude I apologize I reverted
a little bit there I have remember
managing a campaign where we needed to
tackle a truly global piece and it's
like okay you know we're gonna have ads
are going to go good life early say in
Asia and Hong Kong
so those markets and then when it hit
Europe and all of these sort of things
like a gay man how are we going to parse
this out like what's the most meaningful
way and while I am not advocating you
have all of your targeting of one
campaign for the entire world it's not
the best idea you could feasibly do that
when you think of having to add scribble
based on the users time zone versus hero
so yeah the the easiest case for this is
like we do some TV launches and we want
ads to count down or so when a TV show
is going to launch but there's no pretty
Geographic time zones yeah so that's
where this is super useful
so speaking of locations which is got
the other side of this coin I would say
that particularly last couple of years I
feel like you know both the Google side
and the Microsoft side has come mostly
into alignment at least from one how you
target in the types of available
features there's still some minor
differences there but where the
differences start to show is and I wish
I'd grabbed a screenshot there's like a
specific example I apologize that I
didn't but there can be differences in
supported cities counties potentially
even zip codes I forget the numbers now
I wrote an article on this several years
ago on the acquittal blog but there's
like forty forty six thousand plus ZIP
codes in the United States of those I
know at the time Google didn't even
support like ten thousand of them you
know Microsoft somewhere in a similar
vicinity and there's a lot of increases
find that for the you know like how
they're bundled and the way that the
different businesses look at them but
bottom line is is that the zip codes
that Google is effectively ignoring in
the zip codes with it I felt is
effectively ignoring are not the same as
it goes so you need to double-check if
you do an import you pull things over
automatically this check your you add
schedule but then goes straight to
location targeting did my intricately
set up break down the cities or dmas or
states counties whatever the case may be
did that actually come over in the way
that you expected it to into Microsoft
chances are there might be a couple of
things that are red flags yeah and I
can't stress this part enough if we ever
have a problem in import its locations I
live just sort of Washington DC and my
region gets messed up on every import so
it is worth knowing if you're doing just
a state just a country it's going to be
right not but if you get down into DMA
sources MSAs it things can go a little
complicated I'm a hate and I would say
like a question real quick - yeah um
they have dynamic ads running do you is
so do dynamic ad settings
import correctly into Microsoft as well
so and let me just bounce back a
clarifying question and when you say
dynamic ads do you mean dynamic search
ads so I'm guessing
so I'm guessing it's DSA's in if that's
the case then absolutely yes so I had a
list I'm not sure if I put it in here
but basically if you go through and
start checking the boxes of ad types a
type settings etc etc by and large we've
got you covered
I know it's ads I think the only missing
piece is us making a final push into the
quote unquote
it's like fully expanded dynamic search
ad which Google I think put a place like
one five so my go and we'll have later
this summer from a DSA targeting
standpoint you support regex for website
cron but you don't support imported
feeds correct we do have DSA page feeds
how you do okay yeah awesome so in that
case the the auto targets and like how
how you're matching to the feed will
carry over the feed itself will not like
we currently don't have a business data
import connection yet and I don't know
that that's necessarily on our roadmap
we we've got something similar happening
on the Merchant Center site which we
will talk about later but in terms of
the business feed like where that feed
would live that you'll have to bring it
over but in the grand scheme of things
that's a pretty quick to do you know
given that all the rest of the rules
sets will be in place perfect we're
questions answer let's go yeah I love
DSA's by the way it's one of the best
perpetual keyword research machines you
could ever ask for
gotta get a control it but it's pretty
awesome alright speaking of control
let's talk about search partners so we
referenced that early on in the you know
the company man's section of the brain
sedation but now let's talk about search
partners so Google's hat google has
search partners but it's always been a
black box there's really no control
there unless you're you know the biggest
advertisers in the world they can just
be like hey Google we're going stop
spinning unless you block this this one
site most of us are not those people so
on the Microsoft advertising side
however we do still offer control around
search partners and so you know the
first of that being hey you know I want
all search networks I want only owned
and operated that's what Ohno stands for
which would be being
well Yahoo those primary search engines
or I only want to target syndicated
search partners which is a very lengthy
list and those partners bring volume and
specifically mobile volume so that is
where we are seeing a tremendous growth
in mobile is from our syndicated
partners we are putting just a ton of
resources there we have an entire
walking deck that explains all of the
controls automation and people power
that goes into keeping and maintaining
that that network it's insane there's a
lot going on there but there is solid
performance and you know syndication
sometimes get to ding because the
click-through rates aren't always as
strong as on traditional search and
that's fair however it does make up for
in cost per click and I also had another
drop it could have included that
references kind of global cost for
acquisition and it's actually I think
within 20 cents right of what
traditional search was when you look at
it from a top-down perspective which is
pretty darn solid in the grand scheme of
things but then this is really where
things get fun is like I mentioned on
the Google side you really can't do
anything so you know if you've caught
that search partners are like well I do
get a lot of traffic a lot of
conversions through you know there are
some traffic sources in there that are
clearly bringing junk it's really
nothing you can do about that on our
ends you can and so you can look at a
publisher website report in the
dimensions tab it also lives in the
reports tab as well and then let's say
okay well I've got these sites they're
just not working for me
okay well you can add those as
exclusions both at the campaign level
and also at the ad group level so that's
one of those things where I feel like
I've been talking about that for years
and I still see raised eyebrows of
surprise yep this is if you're spending
a grand a month you won't see much here
but if you're spending ten thousand a
hundred thousand a month this is a must
review report like we put this stuff on
our reviews as much as we look at search
search terms it's that important to
really understand how your publishers
are doing and so I love the fact
Microsoft shows this and this one's for
you doctor
go right there number four left six all
right so let's talk bids so you know and
I made reference to this earlier so
different ad platforms means it's a
different competitive landscape so you
know once once the engine is going as it
were things are going to look a little
bit different right you're going to find
hey this keyword I really have to crank
up just because there are so many more
competitors there on bing versus Google
and vice versa so what does that mean
for you okay well you've got to monitor
your performance and adjust accordingly
whether that's in a manual fashion or
implementing some sort of bit automation
and so we look at the kind of the
top-down view of what's happening with
bid strategies across the two platforms
we're pretty close in terms of being in
lockstep here the only gaps for us at
the moment our target impression chair
and target row as I can say confidently
target row ads coming soon
wink-wink nudge-nudge don't know much
about target impression share it's
probably on somebody's roadmap they just
haven't told me so but you know when you
when you're thinking of imported
campaigns or like hey this this
particular feature says you know max
clicks I'm actually an of max clicks in
certain situations let's say you're
using the governor like yeah this really
works well for me we do have that to
offer my recommendation though is bring
your campaigns over run them on manual
CPCs for a bit to get a feel for the
traffic there's something to be said for
just understanding the different data
patterns understanding the bid landscape
before you put in place some sort of
automation because you could set up max
clicks on Microsoft advertising with
with a max CPC setting that's entirely
too low right or maybe it's too high and
you're not really going to know that
until you get some data under your belt
to make a decision so
that's why my word I'm sticking to it
let's talk about a couple of exclusive
features I'll have a lot we do have a
few ad customizers that that's not the
exclusive feature so for those of you
out to raise your hand and ask i love ad
customizers though let's know
effectively one text ad to rule them all
it's a feed based and mechanism that's
really going to say hey let's use some
if-then logic and if somebody is
searching on this keyword and matches
this particular criteria put these words
or this price point or this sale
verbiage into the ad copy
it's truly powerful stuff I think I've
used the phrase before it's living the
dream of truly focused relevant ads for
paid search now where the exclusive part
comes in is that we've baked in
we've been Microsoft advertising we've
baked in the ability to include an
audience ID as one of those criteria so
if you know if this particular keyword
is searched for and they belong in
remarketing list a I need you to serve
this message versus if they're
remarketing list B I need you to serve
this message dude there's that phrase
get it dude that is powerful powerful
stuff so every audience has an ID when
you create a remarketing list in
Microsoft Advertising you discover
naughtiness ID if you have an in market
audience which obviously you didn't
bring that to the table we brought that
to the table for you it also has an ID
you'll note that the spreadsheet that
that screenshot comes from still says
Bing ads I even checked it yesterday it
still says Bing ads folks rebranding in
a big company takes time so bear with us
we're working on it but if I didn't blow
your mind with this one of you take a
minute take a deep breath and let it
sink in this is for me obviously one of
the things that geek out most about in
terms of recent developments in the
world of search I love love love ad
customizers and to apply audiences
there's just tremendously exciting hey
John yeah does that extend to
demographic characteristics
like age and gender - you betcha so
pretty much every layer of targeting
within within the platform is a trying
to think of a right description there it
should be an attribute available
attribute what I can do is after after
we're done here I can track down a link
to the list so we did a webinar on
demographics of in what kind of cases
you want to show a male versus a female
or a young personal person a different
ad and in Google that means duplicating
campaigns or ad groups which is a real
pain but it's super powerful this is
saying you don't have to duplicate it
you just use a feed system and so if you
if you took that what if you haven't
seen the webinar go watch it it's a
really good one but if you took some of
those to heart and you're like yeah we
we actually look at Ages when we think
about our benefits for selling
eyeglasses not which is a really
important consideration this is
fantastic feature it's taking the pretty
amazing opportunities that arose out of
social advertising of you can get really
granular retargeting based on
demographics and because of that then
that you could creates a really tailored
messaging that's effectively taking hey
a searcher saw that we think that's
pretty cool how can we do that in search
I'm not saying it's a one-to-one
correlation but it's certainly follows
the same trend so this one is fun all of
us on this call when we write an ad we
should be including a call to action if
you're not you need to read some of
Brad's amazing articles out on the
interwebs calls to action are super
super important we've won upped that to
say okay yeah you should still likely
write something into your ad however we
do know that ad space is precious and
those of us that are denizens of the
Internet are accustomed to we see a
button we click a button and how can we
play into that behavior and so we've got
the action extension so this is a button
like
clickable button that will show with
your ad in the search results at last
count 69 predefined actions to choose
from you know watch now sign up start
now John I'm name it I was doing an
e-commerce account into being a few
weeks ago and we struggle with this
significantly because every ad has a
unique URL it's a large e-commerce site
call-to-action button is a single URL
right it is yes so is there any way to
make that echo the ad URL there is not
at this moment if I leave some work of
electorial right in yeah it's wonderful
at a free trial it's wonderful download
it's wonderful but sometimes it's one as
a user you need to think about how you
use this because it's a static URL with
a potentially large list of destination
URLs from the ad headline itself I mean
so it can cause them to match so for
sure and I mean my gut didn't go out
yeah my guess is there's probably some
band-aid solutions there right so think
about okay
depending on how you you have your ad
groups broken down but you know these
are like a category page you could send
it to just a test but that's a band-aid
solution given your point right
specificity is always best so if you're
a small website it's amazing and if you
know you want certain things that's
amazing just it's like the promotion
extension and some of Google's price
extensions are not always great you got
to really think through the strategy
this is the same one it's wonderful but
to think about it before you just
implement it blindly right and into your
point yeah I mean on the b2b side often
the calls to action are considerably
clearer
call now contact us that don't I'm not
recommending use contact us but for sake
of example typically quite clear yeah so
another one that you need to think
through is the image extension so those
that have been paying attention now for
a couple of years Microsoft Advertising
has have this extension and play
is quite a while we will even tested one
for a time and then they sunset it
before it ever left a piloting stage and
so ours has maintained in that
dovetailed nicely with our current era
which includes the Microsoft audience
network so let me start with the search
side first this does in fact serve an
image with your ads when you serve them
say position one
it doesn't serve every time I'm not 100%
confident in all of the the backend
variables in terms of what dictates when
it's going to show when it's not however
it is relatively consistent the screen
shot that you see there is real I know
that because my team must be running
that account so you know that's that is
an ad that I had a hand in trading and
so you know again that it's pretty cool
and so when you have an opportunity to
include an image that's relevant whether
it's a product or related to say again
appear on the b2b sides and you're
targeting a specific webinar okay can
you include the image that goes with a
sign-up page for that webinar creating
that one-to-one visual match if we were
to list like you know that the five top
hidden features that only the experts
know when you should be using this is
one of them just FY it's so wonder you
stand it's I mean a search is just text
search results right so putting visual
in there makes a huge difference it's a
big deal and I love that the powers that
be within Microsoft izing you have
allowed this to stick around and now
they have further incentive to do so
so if we've got the Microsoft audience
Network which is our native ad network
we have the ability for you to quote
unquote extend a search campaign so that
means I've got my search campaign which
is keyword base or you got audiences
apply that's all great
you can simply check a box and say I
also want my ads using this combination
of targeting to serve contextually on
the Microsoft audience Network now you
can do that without an image it will
just be a plain Jane text
and in the native environment which can
be affected that does generate traffic
however when you think about native ads
and how and where they show having that
image there makes a complete package and
so the image extension is what enables
that for search campaigns and for those
of you out there that are grumbling like
why do I want to extend a search
campaign to Native it actually performs
better than you might think if you you
know if you start to see that a
particular site from native is not
necessarily performing where you'd like
it you can also exclude it just like you
can with a search partner network so
there's controls there and I think that
there's also incentive wrap kaiser's to
give that a try so to that end what is
the Microsoft audience network so if
native advertising we just talked about
extending search campaigns used to be
called intent ads I think but it was
just called native ads oh don't get me
started on the naming conventions but
now we also have in open beta in the US
it's in a closed beta in the UK in other
countries as well and looking to expand
very quickly beyond that I believe we
should be a global availability
well not global sorry general
availability for the US later this
calendar year and so again thank thank a
Google Display Network campaign on the
Google Ad side this would be analogous
to that but giving you the opportunity
to serve big beautiful ads across MSN
Outlook online as well as Microsoft edge
we do have several partners that we're
piloting at the moment in terms of other
high quality web sites out there and
more will be added over the course of
the next fiscal our fiscal just started
in July it's currently in that but it's
a major major investment area for us as
a business it is working quite well I'm
not going to tell you how much money it
made last year but it made a lot and
that was in Pilot right in innovative
area so it's a big deal a lot of our
biggest advertisers are in love with it
at the moment just simply because in
this end even though it's not the top
traffic site in the world it is still
one of the top
and and you get premium placement right
up there at the top and so if you do
well on display with Google it's worth
giving in San as we love when we call it
the Microsoft foggiest Erica try on this
side of the house
massive reach I'm not going to go in
there's better things for us to talk
about than some of those numbers so
continuing with the thread of exclusives
Brad might Avenue or maybe Dana I don't
rember one of you one of you mentioned
LinkedIn profile targeting towards the
top of this this webinar this one's
pretty exciting so I forget I think it's
one three years ago four years ago
Microsoft bought LinkedIn it was four
and you know myself included like one of
the first things out of our mouths was
that's awesome what does that mean for
big you know what now what does it mean
for Mike's advertising and you know
early on nobody really knew to two
distinct businesses Microsoft actually
allowed LinkedIn to run for the most
part as a standalone business and that
stands true to this day and so if you
think about it in that regard it's been
a complex relationship to say how do we
zipper up all of this data that both of
these distinct companies have in a
meaningful way that show it's one of the
slides I showed earlier protects the
client data on both sides we're not
exposing anything unnecessarily you know
we're not they're not abusing the
relationship that we have with our
clients and customers on both sides and
so it took a while to figure it out but
this is really the first foray into what
that could look like and it is a doozy
so when you think about LinkedIn and how
you have your profiles set up you know
job function what does it I do well I'm
learning strategist so that meaning and
development which tiptoes into a much
broader subset of human resources I
don't think of myself as human resources
but technically speaking that's where
learning and development lives thank
industry think company name right so all
three of those are now targetable
elements within campaign and or an ad
group within Microsoft advertising so
now I just want to give a few ways that
we've used this already and it's only
been out for a few months right mmm a
cow based marketing when people are
doing you know a B M and they're just
trying to target Oracle for the moment
this is one of the few ways to do it if
you are only trying to reach VP's and up
you can do it this way if you are trying
to reach people who with a specific job
title so we sell PPC software people
with things like a PPC analyst as a job
title is not the decision maker but
they're the influencer so that's a
different ad for us than someone who's a
director of digital marketing that's the
decision maker we ascribe to the
Challenger mindset Brenda right yeah
right so I mean that's that is I mean
three of probably twenty ways we've used
this in the past I mean two months three
months at most it's been out um so there
are some really creative ways to use
this data and and I would say - I mean
for b2b it was immediately I get it you
know I'm already on LinkedIn so you know
this is a no-brainer somebody is
searching for my product category on
bing and I can say I want to increase
the bid because they work at this
company and then of course I'm going to
do that you know I think it was the
retail side of the house where there's a
little bit of head scratching going okay
how do I do this in a meaningful way
it's still applicable so if you think
about in-market audiences or any
audience for that matter that you can
apply as a bid only or in the google
vernacular observation right apply them
and watch what happens and you may be
pleasantly surprised right so some of
you particularly that are really savvy
and have marketers out there likely
already have a feel for people in you
know based on my persona research people
in these verticals these industries tend
to be a customer or customer that maybe
spends more with me and if you have that
data this should be a no-brainer for you
as well if you don't this could be a
wave research right so make some
assumptions put them in as bid only
leaving the bid adjustment is zero of
course and just monitor at the data
right see what comes through how many
impressions how many clicks of the
people that are coming through actually
matched to that audience you may be
pleasantly surprised and then they'd
then just decide to up the bet
adjustment
all right so some things that you might
have missed so they're not exclusives
but certainly powerful features
nonetheless and to be honest I feel like
even though there was a marketing push
behind them from from microphone
advertising side it wasn't very loud or
at least didn't feel loud to me
so one of those is scripts and if you're
using scripts in Google ads then why
wouldn't you give them a go in Microsoft
address advertising particularly given
that you can copy and paste the script
over and we have built-in automatic find
and replace so it'll look for AdWords
app or MCC app and automatically replace
it with either being a zap and/or
accounts app I mean that's basically
taking all of the hard an itty gritty
work out of it for you if the script
works at Google bring it over paste it
will do the automatic on a replace and
boom you're good to go and if it is an
unsupported feature something that's in
Google ads that we don't have again our
system automatically flag it as an
unrecognized symbol so so I weapon so
everyone this is why we like to use the
import from Google feature first because
you're going to have things like
campaign aims sometimes or label
features if they're named one thing in
Google something else our Microsoft your
script run but it won't do anything
because they can't find that entity if
you import first you have the exact same
naming conventions so now your scripts
also work
brilliant I had John I just wanna yeah
big caution for everybody
is native it's a caution but I think
that's just it's sage advice right so
naming conventions matter way more than
I think anyone gives it credit for and
that goes in pretty much any advertising
channel you can think of alright now
here's another fun one so campaign
experiments right it's been around in
some form or another on the Google ad
side for several years but Newton knew
for us on the wax shop advertising side
but it's right there in the UI
experiments go through and get that set
up whether it's campaigns and test
settings or budgets or what-have-you
tell us what the ad group level as
keywords audiences pretty much every
level within the campaign grid as you
see it potentially up for an experiment
and so what does that output look like
great okay I'm seeing my experiment I'm
seeing the performance differences and
then from there then you can take action
right what is it you actually want to do
with that
pause experimenting etc so again this is
one where you know is this necessarily
going to push the needle know however if
you are into that granular testing is I
know Brad is experiments can really be a
great way to put put your ideas to the
test product audiences so this would be
you know saying hey I've got my shopping
feed set up and I want to make sure that
I'm tracking for audience purposes
what's happening in my shopping cart
right where they abandoning the cart and
for what products were they actually
shopping for etc all of that is coming
it's in active piloting right now leave
it's an open beta in the US it's working
exceptionally well so this will be
coming live available to everyone quite
soon another good one is similar
audiences and so this is one that you
know I've heard from so many people like
you know we would love to have some sort
of look like audience look like audience
and so that is what this is also in
active piloting currently leave don't
quote me on this and believe it should
be going for global availability
sometime later this calendar year so
quite soon
responsive search ads this one you may
have excised about there's a lot of
debate in the industry right now in
terms of the effectiveness of response
in search ads however if you think about
kind of our mantra of Google parity as
something that we talk about quite a lot
of just making it efficient for you the
advertiser to work with us in a scalable
way is this Delfi falls in line with
that it is an interesting testing
opportunity but that's a whole other
webinar in and of itself I believe and
then last but not least we talked about
ad customizers and I was just raving
about that gushing about that if
functions falls directly in line with
this the difference here is ad
customizers are based on the feed which
can certainly give you a lot of muscle
to flex right dream big
as long as you're proficient in creating
spreadsheets it functions however does
effectively the same thing but directly
within the user interface so no
spreadsheet required and it's just using
base if-then logic so if you can create
an if-then logic statement in Excel you
can do it in the actual ad format so
coming in testing currently yeah so if
you're in Google if you're using ad
customizers you must have an ad without
customizers because they can't replace
it they've got to show something is that
you're also in Bing it does okay so this
is so a functions are great everyone I'm
they're wonderful and it is also a way
to allow some sort of a non add
customizer customized ads because you
can use these as your backup because
there's always something that can show
so if you're really into ad customizers
and you're sort of sick of that other ad
that gets impressions that you really
don't want to show these help you
customize even your backup ads there's a
back door to everything man all right
we've got six minutes to cover shopping
which seems just like such a backhanded
way to treat shopping given its
importance to the industry so we'll move
through this quickly but I just want to
touch on so we've covered Google import
for your campaign structure right in
in whatever you've been doing in the
Google ad system bring it over to
Microsoft advertising to get things
running quickly and efficiently so one
of the my favorite things that happened
last year was this particular feature so
the Google Merchant Center import so for
those of you that are in e-commerce and
you're like it's always pain in the butt
it's like okay what do I do with the
feed do I you know can my system you can
create two different feeds for different
platforms or like if you use a middleman
so like I know for a time I was using a
service called Aten software which would
take the Google feed through the the
Merchant Center API and then you can set
rules to change the community and then
it would spit it back out for Microsoft
that's obnoxious plus cost more money
this says hey you've got your feet in
Google it's set you've done the work
there now you can just pulled over
automatically so this is huge and
particularly if you think about the
recency that's required for a product
feed rate 30-day cycle you can have this
automated so it's pulling it in on the
right schedule that you know matches the
changes that you're making but on the
foot side of that is saying okay yeah
let's get the feed going in an automated
way however you know maybe I want that
cycle to be every two weeks or maybe
just once a month however in the in
between so between those those scheduled
imports how can you make sure that if I
make a change to a price or a
description or not sorry net description
the price and/or the availability of a
product on my site how can I make sure
that that's reflected in my ads well
that's automatic item update so when you
have that enabled you can choose price
only availability only or both and what
this does is it actually uses our our
web crawling bot to go out it's checking
your site constantly anyways in this
case it's bringing some data back to say
ok hey I note this product with that
Product ID it's price change today ok
great it'll change that for you for when
your product ad shows in the search
results that's pretty powerful stuff in
it's literally a checkbox so if you're
into local inventory ads you know again
local e-commerce we've got you covered
look limit or ads or
Center promotions another way to kind of
flex that muscle and get some extra
salesy elements if you will in the
shopping results shopping ads and Bing
images again Bing images is actually
quite popular if you didn't know that
already a lot of people like they still
use Google but they've decide you know
what Google images tinkered enough
they've actually are migrating over to
the Bing images which pool thank you
the hanbok we now have shopping ads
there as well we have a dedicated
shopping tab you learn a little bit too
much about me in this screenshot I'm a
musician and I play video games if you
see the recent search in theirs for
rocket league for the PC the multiple
images experience is another great way
to say okay hey it particularly it's
even clothing shoes anything that's
going to be served well by having
multiple images this is the way that you
take care of that both in your feed but
also in how your ads serves in the
search results so quick quick flash
through shopping but wanted to make sure
that I mentioned that thanks very much
and everyone I just want to say thank
you Brad for joining us and especially
John Lee for putting this all together
thanks for having me John that was a
that was fantastic and hope everyone
takes away the fact that there are a few
buttons you can push without doing huge
amounts of work to get startled the Bing
if you haven't done it or you did it a
year ago and you're like oh gosh maybe I
should revisit this it's still just a
button push so I really do encourage you
to give it a try great thanks Brad and
thanks again John and we hope to talk to
you again thanks everyone
bye-bye
you